allez vous regarder l'entretien sur
france 24 je suis catherine nicholson
aujourd'hui la résidence de
l'ambassadrice britannique à paris je
rencontre la ministre des affaires
étrangères britannique listre ce merci
d'être avec nous c'est une joie d'être
là vous y revenez d'un sommet de l'otan
à madrid et je voulais commencer par
cela le premier ministre britannique à
ce sommet a promis un milliard de livres
sterling supplémentaires dead militaire
pour l'ukraine c'est extrêmement
généreux c'est aussi extrêmement onéreux
combien de temps est-ce que le royaume
uni va continuer à soutenir l'ukraine et
de la sorte nous nous sommes engagés sur
le long terme et c'est également vrai de
la part de nos alliés au sein de l'otan
ainsi que notre allié au sein du g7 ce
que nous avons vu cette semaine cette
unité extraordinaire nous avons vu le
royaume uni s'engager à donner davantage
de soutien en termes d'équipements
militaires ainsi que la france et les
états unis parce que nous avons reconnu
que jusqu'à ce que nous arrivons à aider
l'ukraine à repousser la russie nous
n'ont pas de paix ou de sécurité en
europe donc il ne s'agit pas tout
simplement d'aider l'ukraine même si
c'est extrêmement important il s'agit de
notre propre paix et notre propre
sécurité c'est pour ça qu'il est très
important que le royaume uni ainsi que
tous les alliés contribuer aux efforts
de l'ukraine est en termes de l'impact
en ukraine bien sûr le président
ukrainien volodimir zelensky exprime
toujours sa gratitude pour ce soutien
néanmoins la russie continue d'avancer
dans l'est des petites avancées mais des
avancées néanmoins volodymyr zone ce qui
continue à en appeler à l'occident pour
continuer à fournir des armes lourdes
par exemple est ce qu'il est temps
maintenant pour le royaume uni et
d'autres états d'intervenir pour qu'il y
ait un véritable impact plutôt que cette
guerre d'attrition nous fournissons déjà
des lance-roquettes multiples à
l'ukraine les etats unis aussi je sais
que d'autres pays fournissent des
chardons qu'il y a de l'armement lourd
qui entre en ukraine pour les soutenir
nous faisons tout ce que nous pouvons au
royaume uni pour offrir le soutien que
nous voulons leur donner et nous devons
continuer à se faire avec nos alliés
c'est vital c'est vital pour la sécurité
européenne et nous exhortons tous nos
partenaires à faire ce qu'ils peuvent
comme je les ai déjà dit c'est très cher
et le royaume uni est l'un des soutiens
les plus généreux de l'ukraine 3 8
milliards de livres sterling après
quatre mois de guerre est ce que le
royaume uni va continuer à dépenser
environ 1 milliard par mois comme le
disait nous sommes là pour le long terme
avec nos alliés une des choses que nous
devons faire c'est d'aider les
ukrainiens à remettre leur économie en
marche c'est très très important non
seulement de fournir de l'alimentation
au monde entier et c'est pour ça que
nous traitons des problèmes dans lé port
d'odessa et autres en ukraine est
également important de reconstruire
l'ukraine nous allons avoir une
conférence la semaine prochaine à lugano
pour permettre aux ukrainiens de gagner
d'argent à travers leurs exportations et
de permettre à leurs économies de
fonctionner il ne s'agit pas simplement
de financer une guerre il s'agit de
permettre l'ukraine de fonctionner au
quotidien et nous donnons des fonds à
travers la banque mondiale nous de nous
un soutien financier mais nous devons
aider les ukrainiens à mettre rome être
leur économie en marche et vous avez
parlé de cette unité très forte entre
les nations occidentales quelque chose
dont boris johnson a également parlé à
madrid l'invasion ukrainienne a rendu
l'alliance atlantique plus forte elle a
eu ni l'occident seulement quelques mois
après un refroidissement diplomatique
entre londres et paris liés à la mise en
place de l'alliance militaire au cuss
avec l'australie le royaume-uni et
l'amérique et l'australie a annulé un
contrat d'achat de sous marins français
vous avez rencontré le ministère des
affaires étrangères français durant
cette visite est ce que les relations se
sont améliorées les relations avec la
france au positive nous avons travaillé
en étroite collaboration sur la russie
et l'ukraine et en particulier à travers
le g7 qui a été un organe de
coordination important avec la mise en
place de sanctions et l'union européenne
on a également fait partie c'est une des
raisons pour lesquelles nous avons pu
être efficace avant la nouvelle ministre
des affaires étrangères j'ai travaillé
avec monsieur jean yves le drian pour
être sûr de pouvoir mettre les mesures
en place je veux faire davantage pour
approfondir nos relations avec la france
je crois que nous pouvons faire
davantage dans la région indo pacifique
nous sommes confrontés à des régimes
autoritaires qui investissent dans des
pays de la région pacifique je veux que
des démocraties libre comme la france et
le royaume uni travaillent en plus
étroite collaboration sur ce point là
par ailleurs nous pouvons faire
davantage dans le domaine de l'énergie
nous avons déjà des investissements
considérables de la part de la france
dans le royaume uni dans l'énergie
nucléaire mais il ya davantage à faire
sur la sécurité et la résistance
énergétique une des leçons que nous
avons apprises de cette guerre c'est que
l'europe est devenu trop dépendant du
pétrole et du gaz russe
donc il y à de nombreux domaines de
collaboration et je veux avoir des
relations positives alors éloignons nous
deux le cren j'aimerais parler de ce
qu'il y ait au poste briques sites en
irlande du nord je vais juste donner un
peu de contexte à nos téléspectateurs
vous savez peut-être que le gouvernement
britannique avance sur une législation
qui permettrait au ministre britannique
doute repasser une partie de l'accord
post prick site concernant le protocole
d'irlande du nord c'est la partie de
l'accord sur laquelle la commission
européenne et le royaume uni se sont
accordés pour éviter une frontière
physique en irlande du nord ce qui veut
dire que l'irlande du nord est en fait
encore dans le marché unique alors que
le reste du royaume uni ne l'est pas
alors votre gouvernement a encore avancé
cette semaine sur cette législation avec
un vote au parlement
quel est le but de cette nouvelle loi
la question fondamentale avec le
protocole d'irlande du nord et la
manière dont il fonctionne c'est qu'il
affaiblit l'accord du vendredi saint de
belfast et toute la base de la paix et
la sécurité politique en irlande du nord
l accord de belfast et l'estiment pour
les deux communautés en irlande la
communauté nationaliste et la communauté
unionistes mais ce que nous avons vu à
cause de la friction créés à cause des
relations commerciales entre le royaume
uni et l'irlande du nord parce que les
gens en irlande du nord ne bénéficient
pas des mêmes réductions fiscales que
les citoyens du royaume uni la
communauté unionistes en particulier a
le sentiment que leur communauté est
affaibli et que donc leurs liens avec le
réseau royaume uni est donc affaibli le
résultat de tout cela est que les
institutions politiques en irlande ne
fonctionne pas l'irlande du nord n'a pas
eu de gouvernement depuis février et le
gouvernement du royaume uni doit faire
quelque chose pour restaurer la
stabilité politique
bien évidemment je préférerais le faire
à travers un accord négocié avec l'union
européenne mais pour le moment l'union
européenne n'a pas accepté de changer
les questions critiques dans le
protocole sur les éléments douaniers et
les éléments fiscaux
dont nous avons besoin pour améliorer la
situation en irlande du nord je voulais
dire par ailleurs que nous respectons
tout à fait le besoin de l'union
européenne de protéger le marché unique
nous avons proposé de mettre en place
une ligne verte une ligne rouge pour
nous assurer qu'il ya un vrai suivi pour
que les biens ne puisse pas entrer en
irlande et qu'il reste dans le royaume
uni nous voulons donc une situation
constructive idéalement nous voulons une
solution négociée mais ce que nous ne
pouvons pas permettre c'est que la
situation dégénère ce qui crée cette
instabilité politique il ya quelques
éléments dont j'aimerais continuer à
parler tout d'abord boris johnson
lui-même en 2019 a dit que le protocole
était conforme à l'accord du vendredi
saint est comme ça a été dit aujourd'hui
une majorité des membres de l'assemblée
irlande du nord soutient le protocole le
soutien au protocole est en train de
grandir parmi toutes les communautés et
parmi le les irlandais est ce que le
gouvernement britannique va à l'encontre
de la volonté populaire en irlande du
nord tout d'abord nous avons signé le
protocole mais nous l'avons signé en
théorie avant qu'ils ne soient mises en
oeuvre boris johnson à négocier le
protocole il est un des co-auteurs du
protocole en effet mais ce sur quoi nous
sommes convenus dans l'accord n'a pas
fonctionné sur le terrain et cela crée
des problèmes considérables et je crois
que eu égard à la situation il convient
de trouver une meilleure solution en
terme de négociation vous avez dit que
vous êtes prêts à parler à la commission
européenne
ma cheville le vice président la
commission européenne qui s'occupe de ce
sujet a dit que tant que vous préparé
cette législation la négociation tient
plus de la prise d'otages oui nous avons
eu des pourparlers pendant 18 mois donc
nous avons essayé d'avoir un accord
négocié son devoir passer cette
législation mais ces pourparlers n'ont
pas donné le résultat escompté à cause
d'un refus de changer le texte du
protocole qui est fondamental et je
voulais répondre à l'autre point que
vous avez soulevés sur la situation
politique en irlande du nord à savoir
qu'il ne s'agit pas d'avoir l'accord de
la majorité mais d'obtenir le soutien
des deux communautés en irlande du nord
en obtenant le soutien des deux
communautés c'est ce qui va nous
permettre de permettre à l'exécutif eu
de fonctionner le vice premier ministre
d'irlande les eaux vertes cas a dit
jeudi que votre gouvernement est aligné
uniquement sur les intérêts d'une seule
communauté avec mint et unionistes ce
n'est pas vrai parce que nous voulons
également protéger le commerce entre le
nord et le sud et nous croyons important
de maintenir cette partie du protocole
mais nous devons résoudre les problèmes
entre l'est et l'ouest l'accord du
vendredi saint de belfast est basé sur
l'estiment du deux communautés et croyez
moi que s'il y avait une manière
d'arranger ceux ci qui obtiendrait le
soutien des deux communautés en irlande
du nord sans devoir prendre cette
décision nous nous le ferions bien
entendu mais nous sommes obligés d'agir
et il est légal de le faire à cause de
la nécessité d'une doctrine
international basé sur le principe de la
nécessité mais si les fonctions d'un
état et la stabilité politique sont
affaiblies le gouvernement a la capacité
et à mon avis l'obligation d'agir dans
une situation comme celle ci et nous le
faisons à cause des problèmes de
stabilité et à tous ceux qui disent la
majorité de la population d'irlande du
nord pense ceci ou cela et bien non mais
les institutions politiques ne
fonctionne pas depuis février c'est
aussi un problème de droit international
si je peux me permettre la communauté
européenne a dit très clairement qu'elle
considérait c'était une violation du
droit international
les membres de l'administration byden et
du gouvernement d'irlande du nord sont
d'accord également ils ont des réserves
sur cette législation est ce que vous
êtes soucieux de la réputation du
royaume uni qui historiquement a
toujours soutenu l'état de droit et là
on se retrouve en violation du droit
international oui nous soutenons l'état
de droit et ceci est légal
à cause de la doctrine de nécessité nous
devons agir
parce que l'accord du vendredi saint de
belfast et affaiblies ainsi que la
stabilité en irlande du nord aucune des
deux parties n'a trouvé une solution
alternative pour restaurer les
institutions en irlande du nord et donc
votre gouvernement va continuer dans
cette voie oui mais nous sommes
néanmoins ouvert à une solution négociée
nous restons ouverts à une solution
négociée si il y à une reconnaissance
que je texte du protocole doit être
modifiée mais nous voulons travailler
avec l'union européenne nous voulons
trouver une solution à cette situation
mais ce que je ne peux pas permet c'est
que cette situation dégénère elles
dégénèrent déjà depuis 18 mois il y a un
vrai mécontentement chez les unionistes
en irlande du nord si en tant que
gouvernement britannique la stabilité
politique dans notre pays doit être une
priorité en protégeant l'accord du
vendredi saint
les strass nous sommes à court de temps
mais merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec
nous aujourd'hui merci et merci à vous
aussi d'avoir été avec nous sur france
[Musique]